wer weiß schon freuen
jeder tag ist
er weiß schon heute wie morgen sind wir
morgen wieder alles neu begeht ok liebe
leute es so weit weihnachten steht vor
der tür und in dieser besinnlichen zeit
ist es auch ganz normal dass man
plätzchen offen fisch hat
für die familie für die freunde oder für
wen auch immer
ich hab noch nie gebacken aber ich der
thomas kann uns dann vielleicht ein paar
tipps geben normalsten besten
einfachsten plätzchen dem und
miteinander selber als nicht bäcker
backen
da sind doch nette butterplätzchen mit
er diesen auch gar nicht so schwer als
wir machen butterplätzchen losgeht
diesmal war das wäre dann die schlüssel
7 zucker zitronenschale in butter in
flöckchen untermischen
kurt kannst du den zucker ablegen
das mehl ist wunderbar also 125 gramm
butter genauer an
die butter in flöckchen untermischen das
heißt du musst die klein machen also
plätzchenbacken mit meiner mutter war
irgendwie einfacher so was wollen wir
noch zwei eigelb zwei eigelb deshalb
zwei du musst das eigelb vom highlight
rennen
jetzt immer so mit den branchen zu einem
glatten teig verkneten
fertig was müssen wir jetzt mal geht's
kommt in frischhaltefolie wickeln und
zwei stunden kühl stellen
also wir müssen jetzt den ofen vorheizen
ich glaube auch wie viel grad
du hast 175 grad oben und jetzt kommt
das beste aus rollen
also wir stecken jetzt aus passend zu 16
haben wir ja auch ein violinen schlüssel
so und jetzt heißt es warten also ich
hab die sind fertig das sind also sechs
plätzen gehört aber die sind schon ein
bisschen braun